Donald Trump Jr's fiancee Kimberly
Guilfoyle
absolutely rocked a room full of about
12 people
she is doing everything she can in this
clip to energize the crowd but when the
camera pans to the crowd you see there's
only about a dozen or 15 people in the
crowd it's it's just unbelievable ever
you couldn't write
anything more pathetic than what
actually happened so listen to this and
if you're only listening and not
watching understand that when you hear
the crowd there's like 15 people there
first
[Applause]
oh God look at this crowd a lot of the
people don't even seem to be watching
the speech one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19
20 21 22 23. okay so there's like 30
people in a room that could fit maybe
like 800 or something like that it is
shocking how humiliating this is
to put common sense all right and then
one other humiliating moment from
Kimberly Guilfoyle as if it wasn't bad
enough that's she was doing some kind of
show I guess she has a show on Rumble
now she did her show from CPAC and she
tries to sell silver and gold and she's
reading everything off of a teleprompter
to her right and it's awkward and it's
weird and it's strange and I want to
make sure that you guys
you got gold and silver can protect your
retirement savings from inflation and
dollar devaluation and owning tangible
physical inflation hedging gold and
silver can help diversify your portfolio
you've got to have a diversified
portfolio everybody knows that everyone
goalco has helped thousands of Americans
diversify and protect their retirement
savings support companies who support
you it makes sense 2008 instead of
supporting World Companies who hate you
and use your money to further their
political agenda yeah so go to Kim's
medals it's kind of catchy.com to learn
more that's kimsmetals.com okay so there
it is and making a very powerful
investment suggestion is Kimberly
Guilfoyle a completely absurd CPAC I
mean you could say I'm guessing Saturday
Night Live can't do anything with it
because it it's a parody of itself and
uh Kimberly Guilfoyle Ben Carson all of
these people Nikki Haley they are just
debasing themselves relentlessly and I
have to be honest I absolutely love to
see it let's take a quick break remember
that all of these clips will be on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show